let's talk about bless this mess okay
this show congratulations thank you it's
a brand new show it's doing very well
and on this show you your characters on
a farm mm-hmm and I would think this
would be a great environment for you
because you know Andy and I know you we
know that you are a man who's this guy's
quite handy you are a manly man you know
how to fix things on this show do you
get to show off your skills your real
life skills I do not I would call my
role a reverse Fonzie you know Henry
Winkler was like he's cool but he wasn't
the Fonz he went there and he he put on
the leather jacket and so I know how to
do this stuff and I can't do anything on
the show your character is inept
completely inept at all things physical
and it's kind of like being like a
eunuch on Game of Thrones it's
emasculating and very very hard for me
for my ego I have to pretend I can't
hammer and I things break and fly out of
my hands so in between takes I'll like
put on a real show of like hammerin real
well guys will come over to reset
everything I got all that and then I'll
build something real quick and then tear
it apart don't care no one but me cares
at all whether I can build stuff my wife
doesn't you don't no one cares no but
it's uh it's a struggle
and a real test of my acting because as
you said I'm virtually Bob via below if
you have to take two cracks at his name
than you
[Laughter]
he was the one that never did anything
here yeah it was normally did all the
work okay I'm a veritable norm from this
Bob at work now I'm gonna get you out of
here
we have a clip here from bless this mess
anything we need to know other than the
arteries inept yes some I was it was
learned in the in an episode that
because I inherit a farm on the show and
we are living in New York City we think
this is you and Lake Bell beautiful Lake
Bell who wrote and created this show
hyper talented we leave New York City
and we go to this farm and we think I'll
be great but I used to vacation there as
a kid and so people in town kind of know
me and they used to call me short shorts
and so come to find out I love short
shorts that's all you need to know and
roll this clip from bless this mess girl
yeah somebody orders prime rib this girl
what oh my god they are so small they do
something to me where I just feel so
confident you've been down premium
grade-a USDA
Reiki for families show a little racy
I'm gonna be honest with you I did a
million deadlifts at my trailer before
that seemed I was really hoping my
hamstrings would pop